Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters with a really quick very brief video of cell phones and
cancer some people have likened cell phones to the new cigarette and the damage it affects that a can
Cause cancer though a lot of the studies that are out there will say that it doesn't cause cancer
But if you look at the bias this of those studies
They were funded by cell phone companies. So we got to throw those out the
Studies that are coming out and in fact the World Health Organization just published something last year say that the dangers of
Cell phone cancer or cell phone use and the increase of cancer is real
In an Indian study that we're going to show you in just a second
Cell phone damage
To your brain is really the biggest thing that people are looking at
But it's even more than that even though we can't get into this in this video
The cell phone towers and the radiation that that puts out is even a bigger problem. But right now cell phones
As a person is the younger a person is the more damaging affects that radiation from a cell phone
Happens to their brain as in this little slide here
This is a five-year-old on the left with the the mode of
Pediatrician from that cell phone radiation into that child's brain as a 10-year-old it goes through
Maybe a half to two-thirds of the brain is adopted affects mainly a third of the brain
But that radiation is
Pidotrainated partly it has to do with the thickness of the bone of the skull and the protection that the skull bone gives you
But we can't ignore the effect of the bone
The skull bone itself
With radiation of course children even this young is this picture are using cell phones
So it's not just kids are but it is a
Radiation from cell phones affects the blood-brain barrier which if you look in our brain book
That is the huge issue when we're dealing with brain issues like autism at ADD and Asperger's is a breakdown of that blood-brain barrier
What's that blood-brain barrier is compromised?
Toxins that are circulating your blood from other sources heavy metals and and
Poisons and pesticides et cetera that you cannot be
Cannot not to be exposed to
Could cross the blood-brain barrier that normally should have been protected
By that barrier can get into the brain and cause all sorts of inflammatory
Issues eye cancers ear tumors other cancers. It's just you can't get away from it
The unbiased studies that are out there. Here's one from 2012 published in India
giving you very distinct
Data that cell phone use increases kids are risk
And like I mentioned the World Health Organization study now the truth is is that we could have study after study after study
It more are going to come out because the problem is is that widespread use of cell phones
Is really happened in the last 10 years
In the 1990s it was less than 50% of people use cell phones. That was nearly a hundred percent of adults use cell phones
Ed is young as seven eight nine ten years old kids using cell phones
We're never going to get away from that and even if there's more and more and more data that comes out showing the dangers of cancer and cell phone use
I'll tell you
Myself, I'm never going to stop using my cell phone. I have become
Addicted to it in a way that I'm dependent upon it. That's our mode of communication. So
This is not to tell you to not use your cell phone and we can get into other presentations that tell you how to use your cell phone
Maybe a little more wise
And not where you carry it and how you hold it and such but
This is a presentation that what you can do to protect yourself
On the right of this slide here is a company called Heedron and this is actually a picture of the little disc that goes on the back of your phone
No, I've been telling just a few weeks ago
We were using a disc from
PRL which is fantastic. I still have that on my phone
No, I have both of them on my phone
But that little PRL disc was was great
It always tested perfect with patients and in knocking out the EFFs from their cell phone at least a good
percentage of them the problem was it's about a hundred dollars. So I
Was searching for another avenue the the issue that I found is the ones that are inexpensive that are out there
Never tested that they worked
So there's a lot of scheme or the cell phone that you have to be careful of. These Heedron discs test perfectly is good or even better than the PRL ones
And they're a lot cheaper to be done a ton cheaper
But the regular price of these are $79 and we have a mud sale if you buy a sex pack
Which I'll tell you about the second for 59 bucks
So it's a way to get everybody to your family protected to put them on your iPads your iPhones your
Your laptops and just keep yourself as protected as possible
It's a matter of you can't run away from the EFFs
But you could protect yourself and be as wise as possible
You simply take that this little sticker
And you put it on the back of your laptop or your cell phone though the right of this picture
It shows it just one of the back of the cell phone of the left
They're showing four of the back of a big computer screen
So one will give you a lot of protection
Obviously four would be best at a great big computer screen
But you have to just kind of use your
You know financial ability to be able to put as many as you possibly could use
I'd never suggest more than one of the cell phone for instance
Cell phone is it is your huge EFF producer that you have right decks to your body
Computer screens at least you don't have it your head up against the computer screen. We hope but
They're important. So
The reason why we're starting to carry these over the PRL is I think they work better
They they're not as bulky on the phone. They don't stick out as much because that was an issue with the PRL product
And then phone cases wouldn't fit over them. These phone cases typically fit right over them. They're more flat
They're about 27% cheaper and now on sale. They're about 40% cheaper
So it's just a way to get more people to have them
Whether when things that are great for you are cost prohibitive. That's a struggle
The other nice thing about these is the PRL ones if you change your phone and you peeled it off your phone
Typically you damaged it and it was worthless. These peel off nicely
So they will last forever too. They are something that you need to replace
So it's a one-time purchase. You could use it. People get new cell phones a lot
You could peel it off and put it on a new cell phone that tends to work better
Here's the leg I haven't figured out how to put a leg that you could actually click on on a video
But in this email
There is also a leg that you can click on and you can purchase it on our sale price if you go to our store from our website
It's the $70 but if you click on this email and click on the leg you have the sale price and the six pack price
Okay, hope this benefits somebody and we'll talk to you soon